Wow this is awesome you know I mean this
is like challenging in a way I have
never have never experienced this hey
what's going on everybody four first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Ilana Glazer and Abbi
Jacobson together they're the stars and
creators of broad city now entering its
fifth and final season Thursdays on
Comedy Central
ladies welcome to the show thank you for
having us we are really excited and
anxious to be here and for the second
time we have since the great Joey cocoa
Diaz we have not had guests bring bleu
cheese to the table today that changes
the bleu cheese yeah I am stoked about
that that's gonna help on that house in
sight all right well you guys ready to
get it started yeah
so this first one's the classics Cheers
watch what if I die just from this one
I'm like God I don't know just like I
know
[Music]
so we're doing cauliflower yeah really
good right yeah okay this is hotter than
I expected you see I am like this is
like the kind of like you in for a
freaking round edge so you guys have
received a lot of well-deserved
attention for your comedy but Ilana one
thing that I think you deserve a lot
more credit for is trailblazing
the sort of twitch generation that we
have now with your series chronic gamer
oh I was talking about I can't leave you
said this I just was talking last night
about um doing chronic gamer girl on
Twitch it's so different twitch seems
from TV so if this like online community
millions and millions of followers and
it's like we're you know but they're
like teenagers you have celebrities like
ninja who'll make millions of dollars a
year plaintiff or I'm also like who I
don't we because I wanna I didn't have
not said a thing I don't know it's like
Abby has no idea we're talking about I
only have an idea but I don't know it
intimately
either I know what fortnight is I don't
totally get it you want to move on to
number two I know what fortnight is not
quite yet sorry sorry I'm so um wait
I'll finish the conversation I'm so an
actual wasn't rolling it okay I know
what it is just so we both cool okay
fortnight gamer you know I don't play oh
it was making a mobile game with dildos
bongs and a jonbenét Ramsey beanie baby
the culmination of your gaming dreams
I'll talk about like I play it and talk
about like a simple enough game for
these idiots but also they do the one
thing about it is there is an image of
us and I am like we're going like this
and they made me look like I'm a
bodybuilder it's like fudge your pistons
but okay it's it's okay I think it's
like hot in a different way than you're
versatile thank ya
[Music]
okay this one's like sweeter I like
these first two mm-hmm
yeah enjoy that like you know like we're
wine back to that you guys have become
an inspiration for a lot of
do-it-yourself creators and that you
took broad city from this bootstrapping
webseries into this elaborately produced
show on Comedy Central and here at hot
ones we sometimes wonder what we'd even
do if we had a budget like I don't even
even know how it gussied up this freak
show I love that and I'm curious when
Comedy Central cut the check for broad
city season one what was the most
amazing new way you found you could
spend cash and then what was the most
wasteful we used to do this for $10
thing we were like stealing every shot
stealing every location unless we're in
a pizza shop when we paid them like $50
right to let us shoot there we're
stealing it sort especially the subway
stuff that it's so difficult to shoot
with an actual like once you have a
legit show they're like you can't shoot
here for free so it was also like all
this stuff that cost so much money that
caused us I know it was like running
tonight I'm okay
I like this one into that one too as
showrunners and stars of the show I'm
curious what was the biggest
pain-in-the-ass scene to pull off it's
my own fault because I was also
directing the episode and I picked this
location that was like in the middle of
Madison Square Park kind of like on the
outside but we it's like we were full o
fully watched by the city like come
shooting and it's you see the full oh my
god and it was a pain in my ass
it was all of us it was the hottest day
days two days the century like it was it
was like global warming is a story get
ready [ __ ] the earth is burning yeah
damn I had this like tube top that is
was it was like full of titty sweat and
we're trying on a 96 degree day trying
to dry it with a blow dryer it was it
was torture and I also was starting to
get on my neck from this like choker I
was like heavy rains oh because I was so
angry and then also cold the bridge oh
also fun fact the bridge pedestrian
walkway not closed that's running [ __ ]
you idiot flipping out and I cover the
Manhattan Bridge are you insane our crew
is do you mind
it was nut it's crazy okay I gotta say
the third one I didn't eat this little
bit not because of the slice because I
truly am getting full we're eating like
a full head right budget a budget
I feel like hi here
[Music]
okay I'm starting to get nervous
virtual it's just a totally different
flavor hot so broad city is rife with
weed references and year over a year you
guys bless the internet with these 4/20
specials I know it's a show but clearly
you write what you know
have you ever actually made the
firecrackers oh yeah no not smoothie
just firecrackers without making it a
smoothie it's like so much grosser right
yeah it's like I'm eating dirt which I
like you're just eating weed yeah I feel
like that like you know like mushrooms
you know I mean you're like you know
instead of like you know whatever doing
something with it but um I don't know
what it was it was like bang for your
buck like get as high as possible
cheaply which isn't I'm not condoning
that but I'm like 31 you know II mean so
it's like whatever I'm not there anymore
um
you mash up weed into something really
fat based lays a butter almond butter or
Goa or Nutella as I love that way better
yeah that's dough well I'm like a health
nut so I do my butter and to have like
the fat thing you can put it on rice
cracker graham cracker or whatever or
you could just put it straight up on a
baking sheet and put it on something
after you do like 17 seconds in the
microwave 22 minutes in the put on a
graham cracker and then crack yeah oh
and when you're when it's in the up and
you put it in tin foil and we would lose
our minds we would be like this is
hilarious Cheers
we eat it and then be like I'll be right
back and we will like go into fetal
position in our respective rooms and I
used to like I don't do edibles yeah
because I was doing the crack
firecrackers you know I mean like the
crack of wheat
oh okay get in there but it's Magreb
tasty like really pretty good phone all
right guys we have a recurrence segment
on our show called explain that Graham
where we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context Ilana your Instagram
is just one video of a girl trust
falling in a school - right now it is
yeah because I I wanted like a fresh
start for 2019 Oh changes happening but
I could this girl in high school it's
like falling on people
it honestly brings out such a distilled
what kind of person are you
there's this one boy this cute little
boy who like perfectly perfect form
catches her and he's like he's so cute
and most people are like ah like in high
school like dicks but the teacher
catches her which I was like gasps dude
and then this little boy is like oh yeah
she's falling and she is hilarious she's
just like throwing herself on the ground
this is so funny we're gonna go through
my Instagram which I am in as well
constantly talking about how I want to
delete my social media accounts well
you're just a little bit late to that
you know because now you're on the show
where we dig it all right let's revisit
oh that is on like Seth Meyers he knew
the show yeah uh-huh he came over I was
like I'm not sure but I don't want it
there's like hey Moe and I go over to
someone shares like nerve I know crazy
my mother honey Oh yours cracking me
yeah he's so sweet right and drew met
him that day - yeah Ilana and I had
shared assistant true and I was like
Shaq can dream come over because he's
like obsessive she was like yeah I met
you I know okay
let's revisit some of these do you know
this I know what that is yes I wrote an
autobiography when I was maybe testing
the chapter on ice
Charlie get in there and this is like
the questions that I guess the teachers
like propose that was so cute answered
little color purple and black yeah
singer boys to men seasons winter summer
okay my numbers are eighty eight and
twenty two which are two Philadelphia
Flyers numbers Eric Lindros and the 88
and Ron Hextall
your favorite flower is zinnias how
mature is that oh my god and Abby's
favorite name's Toni
Kimmy and Abbi wait this is cool
Legos I was a Lego that's so cute
ice cream top chip cookie dough good
idea [ __ ] that's cool
okay you all right I'm fine
this one has like seed and chick do you
feel this one yeah I don't know what's
going on man I don't know I mean I'm
like my face is sweating but I'm
chilling
it's like many aspiring comedians who
have come to NYC you guys had more than
your fair share of odd jobs along the
way what do you remember - what do you
remember about working together at a
coupon service for salons spas I'm like
this is like very spicy to me I love it
there you know I mean it clears it does
make me feel like I'm wild okay um what
are you talking about so I like um life
Booker's what it's caught I remember
working on broad city from two feet away
you don't I mean and like we're each
adding like scripts we had to make we
had to pretend that we were working but
the job was to get salons and beauty and
fitness services to do a deal with
lightwalker
and I did in New York and in LA you know
it was so funny it's like a be like
doing a deal with Jerry from the hair
salon it was like Jer what's up anyway
you know it was like so later we got on
the Kerr straightening can you do a 60%
off that I come on Jer it was really
funny it was such like bull shadows it
was such [ __ ] we're always like
taking I got to go take lunch but it
like taking like long ass breaks you
would smoke in the hall in the stairway
be it I'm an idiot it's not gonna stare
a little bit like out the window like
there weren't like pens then does it
make your mouth like very much salivate
more yeah cool and your nose really nice
okay great now you're nuts you're eating
hot wings you're the next one are you
ready for this yeah are you gonna do oh
just so you're popping it in your mouth
fully yep okay I don't think I can do
that
do whatever you know
[Music]
Oh top
that is hot so there are some famous UCB
hangouts including the peter macmannus
cafe in chelsea wait what I'm just like
feeling sorry I just had to like
describe like my tongue has its own heat
engine going on so you're going on the
journey along with your tongue it's like
this like friend I have like I am like
you guys ever grab meals there after him
practice or anything like that way back
yeah like chicken fingers and fries I
for dinner every night right chicken
fingers but it was such a bar it's like
such fried and also like you reminded me
recently about the hierarchy of like
being in the main area by like being
alcoholic regulars and like you know
some like old person really hanging next
to them and then like getting to go into
like the ripped nylon green booths in
the back eventually like there were it
was such a scene for us
it's stained me building a little bit
and like also going back in my throat
like like I'm finding myself having my
speech obstructed yes
[Music]
that's right Wow okay
I see holy [ __ ] oh it goes way back um
like that is it that is now like
something fire so as we've touched now
already you guys have been making comedy
for a decade long and one of these BFF
relationships that seems to endure from
the set to real life but now it's time
to put that to the test with a little
segment we call the bucket Oh BFF
questions and here's how it works
we have some questions in the bucket
Alanna you'll reach into the bucket
that's the question Abbey or you'll
reach in the bucket ask the question to
Alanna what is happening so you reach
into the bucket and then you ask the
question to a lot okay
I need a tissue
Hana I would I'd get a spoon I'm coming
in tissue on dak Oh Alana did you ever
have a moment where you were concerned
the fame went to my head yep I can't
believe this Oh what is my most annoying
habit when I'm high Oh Oh you just
answered mine yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's your rose annoying haven't when
you're high maybe thinking you're like
not high yet what's the one thing that
online trolls get right about me not the
fam got your head
Oh Ice Cube pops oh my [ __ ] yeah this is
fine you having a good time
this is a star club Wow I feel nauseous
yeah I feel so many maybe I had an idea
for an episode that doesn't feature me
know everybody all right so we've made
it through the bucket we've made it
through the bomb we have to one moment
yes right there is just a moment like a
moment ago when you were going into the
bucket that my mouth got cold and no
that's a bad sign right gets cold it was
cold how fire fear this good okay
[Music]
smart now you got the the IceCube chaser
[Music]
oh so in addition to the hilarious
writing on the show it seems like a lot
of the ways that you guys crack each
other out there's not so much in what's
being said all the time but how it's
being said and I'm curious to what
extent do you attribute that to being
from Long Island in Philadelphia to
places where accents and slang are very
much baked into the identity of the
locals well it's also just like I guess
like the shades of whiteness and
suburbia and the shades of like
Jewishness make us laugh to pick them
apart and it's just like who [ __ ]
cares you know the thing that's also
part of it it's like different flavors
of the same juice hero or hero or sub
and she's like gotta get hoagie bro okay
brother oh my god I just got to a
plateau of relief that's a good place to
be that's a good place [ __ ]
wow this is awesome you know I mean this
is like challenging in a way I have
never have never experienced this what's
the most Long Island sentence you can
hit off the top of your head
oh I don't know um like Mike's picking
me up in the Hummer and then we're going
over my dad's and then we're gonna drive
to the beach and there's I'm not good
yeah Long Island hmm I feel hot
but what's that what's happening here
[Music]
so this is the last dab we call it the
last day because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
wing you don't have to I'm sorry I don't
want to I'm sorry but can there be more
ice added to the pitcher
that's an interesting logistical
challenge for a team or just a cup of
ice and all adds up in temperature we
got you oh I'll do it just because this
is fun
me too I guess we're gonna put the whole
thing on um no I don't think so okay you
don't know that yet that's a thing oh I
was gonna balance it all right on here
oh my goodness okay
did you eat this yet
this is the same process that on here
already cheers from cauliflower bite
number one - cauliflower bite number ten
help put the ice hmm you're [ __ ] hot
let's do Falcon huh what is that oh my
god I just I'm getting chills
I'm getting chills yeah whoo that's like
a pre puke it was a symptom yeah nice
coming through ice coming through and
here we are at our journeys and just one
more hoop to jump through and you've
talked a lot about what make Abbi and
Ilana tick from the do-it-yourself
spirit that has made broad city one of
the most beloved shows on television to
your roots and improv but one thing we
haven't discussed is your shared love
for Bed Bath & Beyond
so now with our lips on fire mouths
ablaze brains seared with hot sauce I
need to know why is that one-stop-shop
for electronics cookware and towels the
greatest chain in the world
so with middle school high school my mom
worked at the bathroom yacht a couple
different ones in the suburban
Philadelphia area and she was really
good friends with like this cast of
characters they were all so friendly and
totally like just loved working there
they have also been like awesome nuts
they let us shoot in there twice I would
just go there with my mom would be like
Marshalls in bed bath here I mean so
like our usual obviously you know like
walk a little car at picture table or no
I'll show it so you know everything
there
I still use fun mmm
I like the facade of making us bring
makuu I like this and I think these
first two I'm like it's like a throwback
to paper well very compelling case made
and look at you Alanna and a v10
cauliflower chicken wings up ten
cauliflower chicken wings down and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you guys this camera
this camera and this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life well you guys gotta watch the
show broad city it's the second episode
airs tonight a Comedy Central this is
the last season big deal I'm like
freezing work it's very cool yeah weird
I'm like chilled I think that you're
gonna love it
dude it just so good season 5 was so
good and also I'm like out here saying
it right cities one of the best shows on
TV ever
it's so [ __ ] money I [ __ ] love it
it's my favorite show that was so good
great job you enjoy it I did you even
though it was like paint really painful
I carved it cuz it's so different I like
my tongue is so numb hey what's going on
everybody this is Sean Evans checking in
with a quick hot sauce update if you'd
like to try the classic Louis Caliente
so the last abric ducks heat nice calm
heat miss calm has you covered if hot
sauce isn't your thing maybe check out a
t-shirt or a hoodie over at shop complex
calm and if none of that interests you I
have been really getting into macho
lately matcha latte as much as smoothies
much of pudding I don't know how I went
32 years on this planet without
discovering matcha but now I have and it
has been a complete game changer we
don't sell any matcha products
whatsoever but I'm just saying you
should try it out